Julian Chevalier lead designer on
valiant hearts told me we wanted to do a
game about world war one but not a war
game so that's why you don't kill people
the war kills them but you don't kill
them it's a game that puts a human face
on war focusing on how world war 1
impacted the lives of ordinary people
you hop between characters playing as an
American soldier named Freddy an older
French soldier named Emile and a nurse
named Anna among others this isn't a
story of good vs evil but if people
swept up in a conflict that is beyond
their control valiant hearts isn't all
tragedy in sorrow it makes time for
moments of sweetness and exuberance a
cute dog helps you solve many of the
games simple puzzles and your
interactions with him may bring a smile
to your face despite the devastation the
characters have experienced and in one
inspired sequence anna drives through
the bustling streets of paris as you
navigate obstacles that appear in rhythm
with the music it's a joyous moment the
simple gameplay aims to communicate the
ordinary nature of the characters this
is not a power fantasy and you don't
play as powerful killing machines you
distract soldiers by throwing objects
and sometimes just try to avoid the
death and destruction happening around
you even when things are grim the art
style should keep the game story
approachable for children and adults
alike valiant hearts will be released on
jun 25th for xbox one xbox 360
playstation 3 playstation 4 and pc
you